[Music]
let's go down the road ad to roow ads to
talk to Nikki in Knoxville Tennessee
what's up
Nikki hey how are you I mean literally
couldn't be better that's probably a
little bit of exaggeration but I'm doing
great how about
you I'm doing good now Mary Mary did you
know is never going to be the same to me
again because she knew right yeah right
and never thought of it that way so now
ceelo's version was one of my favorites
not
anymore okay all right I was I get us
just get us derailed all right go for it
so what's
up so um how can I what can I do about
my husband that degrades Bel little me
and cusses me out specifically to me but
also in front of my four-year-old
daughter get
out yeah I know it was a really been
really nervous because it wasn't an easy
question to ask yeah and I appreciate
you saying that and I'm I I I'm both
sorry and not sorry that I've got such a
viseral response to
that um that is either he goes or you go
um and with since there's a little one
it's it's best if he goes and yall need
to take a 30-day separation is this
pervasive does this happen all the
time not all of the time I feel like
it'll be like a month that's really good
maybe up till 2 months and then it will
just then it will happen and then it
will be a week of not talking him giving
me the silent
treatment um it it always gets flipped
to like it's my fault you know or ites I
wouldn't have acted that way if you
didn't do this yeah cuz he married a
seven-year-old I literally had that
conversation with a with my
seven-year-old the other day when she's
like my my her brother he made me and I
stopped and said no he didn't no he
didn't yep your feelings feel big and it
feels like you can't control him and
that's what my job is is to teach you
and help you and walk alongside you but
he didn't make you do anything he make
you hit him he didn't make you what
right and you you're made to a
seven-year-old in a humongous male body
that is such a coward he decides to yell
and scream at his wife in front of his
child yeah I mean that's the height of
cowardice the only the only step further
is to hit somebody um in that situation
has he ever been violent with you no he
hasn't been violent no that luckily the
two things I always said is I can never
imagine him cheating or laying hands on
me yeah but she when I say you couldn't
have imagined him talking to you this
way
either yeah yeah it's true right what in
the world sets him
off honestly I feel like it could be I
mean it could be any number of things
even something is little like last week
where um in my field of work all there's
C certain times where I have to train
people and I'll be gone a little bit
more often and keep in mind like I'm the
bread winner I I have I have to you know
and so and I'll tell him like I and I
know he's going to get mad so I have to
gear up to it like listen this week I'm
going to work five days instead of my
normal three or four so um like be
prepared you know and why in the world
would he get I'm not I promise I'm not
I'm not raising my voice at you I would
hug you if you're here I know I know why
in the
world when you're the bread winner does
he get mad a when you're going to serve
somebody and teach them and train them
and B you're gonna make more money
why do it cut into his video game
time yeah right yeah it's well I I
that's the thing that I have such a hard
time with because it'll be like before
when I wasn't training people he's like
you're not working to your full capacity
you do so good at training people I
don't know why you do or why you don't
and then I do and it it's only you you
just prioritize your job your job's only
when that's important I have to be the
one to take care of the daughter and all
that you know it's so I feel like no
matter what I do it's wrong there you go
you know why because he's moving the
he's moving the Finish Line because this
has zero to do with
you this has to do with whatever he's
going through or working through he's
unwilling to do it unable to do it
whatever I don't care what I'm looking
at is the resulting Behavior and the
resulting behavior is you live with a
seven-year-old the body of a grown
man MH and he doesn't get to talk to you
that way he doesn't get to talk that way
in front of your
kid yeah who is this guy like don't I
don't know his name but like tell me
about him what makes him so great and
wonderful that he can just spit on his
wife like
this I
well I don't know he's he's a big
muscular dude he takes a lot of pride in
his Fitness and he's I mean I I guess
when I listen to your podcast you'd
probably describe him as self-righteous
when I describe him you know this way
like he's always always acts like he's
super busy but really doesn't have a
whole lot to do or
um I I don't know he's he's always has
to be the leader he always Prides
himself on being such a
man but then he treats me like this and
it's like well you want to pride
yourself on being a man then act like
one you know it's one of the least
masculine things a man can do is to
treat those he has been charged and not
only charged but committed he opted in
to this relationship with you he opted
into Parenthood by Sleeping with you and
to op to those you have opted in to love
and honor and take care of the least
masculine thing you can do is use them
to wipe your boots
off to use to to do anything other than
be out in the marketplace trying to make
your community better earn a living for
your
family sure go to the gym that's an
important part of it but I did my gym
work this morning and I worked out hard
before anybody was
up yeah
right yeah and well and and there's like
a few other pieces to it too where I'm
like man I I kept thinking if maybe if
he just does one this one thing it'll be
better this thing like he's been seeing
a counsel now for a year and a half we
did marital counseling for a year he he
runs a Men's Ministry like good God it's
things like that where I'm like man like
I like he's the last person that should
be running a Ministry for
men and that's my thing but if I ever
said that of course I would be
like it would be if you ever said hey
your behavior at home and the way you
treat me and our daughter doesn't align
with the lesson you're teaching these
men he would respond by cursing and
yelling
and right he would just he would exactly
roll into what you
said I've probably let it slip before to
be honest you know there's like a saying
oh oh I have said before I wish that
some of the guys from your group could
see the way that you speak to me because
they wouldn't be attending anymore you
know and and what's his response to
that his typical responses well he'll
either go to the most extreme and say
something like I'm going how about I be
how about I actually start to be a
terrible husband so you could see what
it's like to have a hard life or or
you're such a victim you always have a
victim mentality and all right so here's
here's the path okay I can't make you do
what I'm about to
say and I've only got to talk to you for
a few minutes and so I don't even know
if it's the right thing but based on
what you've told me if you were my
sister or you were my like one of my my
close
friends if you were a female coworker of
mine and you said what you have just
told me I would say you're right I'm
done being a
victim nobody in the world especially
the one
guy that got on the knee before me and
God and our families and said I will
defend and protect and love and care for
you especially him but
nobody gets to yell and scream and curse
at me nobody gets to belittle me
especially in front of our
daughter nobody gets to teach my
daughter that this is what love and
commitment and Fidelity and marriage
looks
like
period And if it happens to be the
person I married I'm done being a victim
I make the money in this house I raise
the kid in this
house behaviors of language you are
asking me with all of your big muscles
for me to
leave and I hear you loud and
clear so then the other caveat to that
is we we moved two and a half years ago
across the country so it's like what
then I consider like well where would I
go what would I do I could drive back to
my family's house then I leave my
business and everything behind like it
you know it's it's the logistics part
that's obviously the scary part and then
of course when it's when there things
are good they're really good we have a
lot of fun we have the same interest but
but you never exhale in your own home
Nikki you never fully exhale in your own
home yeah that's
true yeah like walking on eggshell
always and when it's good you're
performing you're you're singing and
dancing and he happens to like your song
on that
day
yeah that's really true yeah like as
long as I behave that's the kind of way
it is as long as I'm what he wants he's
happy
man here's the deal there is no there's
no easy path forward for you period
every step forward is going to be
hard because you're married to somebody
that doesn't Honor doesn't love and
doesn't care for
you period so every step forward is
going to be hard being a single mom I
can't even wrap my head around how hard
that would be having to start a business
back at home where I've got Family
Resources would be unimaginably
hard and you've proven to yourself that
you can take care of your daughter's
needs pretty much by yourself maybe even
in spite of your husband you've proven
to yourself you can move to a new
community and make be the breadwinner of
a family in just a couple of
years yeah or staying in the middle of
this
mess that's going to be hard too and I
can't make that call for
you yeah that's a good good perspective
though there's no there's no path
forward that's not really challenging so
I'm going to tell you the same thing I I
I I you got to choose your heart you got
to choose your challenge here my hope is
that you choose the challenge that leads
to you being free to you being honored
and respected to you being um able to
show your daughter what strength and
respect and resilience and love and
character looks
like that's my hope but I can't make you
do
that yeah anytime I have something very
very hard to do a hard choice to make I
always go to my identity first and then
I reverse engineer it here's who I'm
going to
be I'm going to be a guy that can tell
the truth I'm going to be a guy that
takes care of himself whatever the thing
is and then I have to reverse engineer
the hard things all right if I'm a guy
that take is a good Steward of his body
the one the one body God gave
me and I've got kids and I got um a
marriage and I got work that's 247 365
all that means I got to work out at 4
o'clock in the morning sometimes that
means I got to work out at 5:30 that
means today I had to cut it quick and
that mean when I was cutting it quick I
had to go real hard like I'm going to
reverse engineer the stuff from my
identity the person I'm going to
become mm
yeah that's a good way to put it I it's
I I feel like the I feel like the
hardest part is when you know it would
be easy if it was always bad or like my
daughter's obsessed with her dad like
she loves him so much that's the hard
like I I know you're right something
crazy nikk can I tell you something
crazy me yeah tell me I've mentioned
this on the show before but it was like
a lightning bolt in my soul when I was
working with a
um one of my practicum supervisors was a
guy who worked with abused
children and I remember leaving one of
the sessions one day or a conversation
we were having and I said well that
kid's going to be
okay and he looked at me and said hey
John Straight A's can be a trauma
response
to oh wow and you have fight and you
have fight and you have flee and there's
a fourth one that is less common less
talked about there's fight fight flee
and
fawn I'm GNA nuzzle up so
close that maybe they won't get me
there I'm going to be extra sexual I'm
going to be extra close I'm going to be
extra nuzzle I'm going to be extra
tender CU like in boxing sometimes the
safest place to be to someone who hits
really hard is close as humanly possible
to him
yeah and so just because a kid nuzzles
up to their
dad doesn't mean that oh she sees how
wonderful he is no she may innately know
the safest place is real real
close that's true because especially
after he'll yell or whatever that's the
other thing that kills me is that I'll
see happen is for instance she'll do
something or have an outburst and he'll
get upset with her and she'll say like
she'll look at him and go do you love me
Dad you love me Dad and sometimes like
if he really she really just frustrated
him he'll just look at her and go yeah
and kind of look away and I've had tell
them like hey like don't teach her that
your your love is only contingent on
what she does for
you but then I guess now that I just say
that out loud that that's what happens
to me
too
yeah and I'm getting choked up now too
cuz I have a seven-year-old little
girl
yeah so here's all I can tell you Nikki
I can't I can't I can't make you do
anything I'd love to talk to him
something went sideways in his life I
don't know what it
is I can just tell you you're worth more
than
this and for God's sakes that little
baby girl is worth more than
this and just by nature of a lot of my
higher ed work my job with college
students I'm going to put the you're
right your mom is watching you and
learning what safety looks like how to
be safe in a house with a volatile
unpredictable loud withholding
adult that's trauma by the
way trauma with a with a with a big te
on it
trauma and she's watching oh this is how
we deal with this
situation
and the number of students I've sat with
over the years that have completely lost
their faith walked away from any sort of
faith it was almost never about the
faith
it was about people proclaiming one
thing and then living another way that
the kids over a period of their
childhood could not reconcile the
cognitive distance between who this
person is espousing to be and who they
actually
are and they just say I don't I don't
know what to do with this but I'm
out because if this is what this is I'm
out and you do that for 18 years it
becomes part of your nervous system and
somebody starts talking about faith and
your body's like dude get out of here
and so we we make often make people
walking away from Faith about a about a
intellectual issue it's a nervous system
issue get me out of here this is not
safe it's the same as to your daughter
one day I love you will you marry me and
her body will say get out of here not
safe
and he's getting some help he's doing
all the quote unquote right things going
to a counselor but he is not changing
his life period and you were not put on
this planet to be his
doormat but I can't make you leave and I
can't make you have a hard
conversation and I can't make him
change I love you I love him too good
grief man there's a lot of hurt in that
house